cabanne habit a habit of who would he go
sing go Ambrose my name's Pierre
welcome back to some more outlast
whistleblower gonna do a sex change
[Applause]
no I'm so sorry don't love everybody
it takes my mind about the dress thing
rude ah [ __ ] nasty man this game is
meh' yes finally it's my turn yang
[Music]
oh you have amazing bone structure
Sasuke you're going to be beautiful
I want to purchase a guy a woman has to
suffer it's not pleasant but just try to
and you are
for my sake for the sake of our children
can't you see that the pain is you
[ __ ] sicko take long few snips of the
flesh
[Music]
cutaway
vulgar
[Music]
Oh step by where the [ __ ] is that my
balls okay my balls okay what the [ __ ] I
want how do I get back on I don't know
thing oh that's so [ __ ] up
can I go home now I think I deserve a
hike a lot what the fine
I'm nobody's mother nobody make any
sense
rotten how hell please cray-cray oh [ __ ]
just I'm just going I'm just going for
that man
Oh watch that fricative broker on my
name namely du coeur oh that's cool
exit
[Applause]
[Music]
don't like you our feet may leave okay
hi ma'am great weather today we've been
very lucky
[Music]
sorry these stories come out [ __ ] oh he
sure knows how to stab a [ __ ]
I'll hand him that
nope
[Music]
why don't come hi how dare you call me a
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] but I'm not a [ __ ]
different it is look it up in a
dictionary get it
so [ __ ] mean
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
I just want to go home so badly you have
no idea
Oh God
please please I'll just gotta hurt
that's right I'm a [ __ ] and I got it in
before it's like she doesn't realize so
me we had something special
[ __ ] weirdo man [ __ ] me yes okay
oh well I gots to do I guess I'll go
here then fantastic I'll just link my
way through this game now [ __ ] why why
exit tell me why I need an answer okay
bucket did you lock the door bucket
don't give me that look vacuum all right
well I guess on a quest to find a little
key that's a CD batteries when the
morning was gone and you can go on oh
we've been through so much
we've been through so very much but hey
what are you gonna do about it one give
me something and nothing oh here we go
oh hey bro thank you for being oh we're
here now my god that is so [ __ ] up
that is so [ __ ] [ __ ] up
I had a great gymnastic team cell game
night
Jesus
[Music]
it's it really that [ __ ] again
I am a girl you had it all you had a
beautiful girl a beautiful 10th possum
tit for that matter oh he's that guy
again [ __ ] that guy
oh I'm not a [ __ ]
I swear I'm not a slide you don't know
me
asked me out on a date first then you
know what am I doing here oh god I need
to move that thing oh god why did I do
that quicker I got it I need to move it
this way come on
no don't kill me I'm an innocent Swede
sweetheart what is he still after me I
hate him so much
where there hi amigo there we go
I don't like to be kissed potato and a
bit all right I am took a long break oh
my god
I can't handle this
why does he want me so much I mean I
know have a nice ass and everything but
it's like gone it's not that great I
could just jump here oh my god why don't
I just go it oh that's why what the [ __ ]
just happened
ha ha ha ha ha ha who's that you [ __ ]
used to force on me this is they give me
an early review copy so that's why but I
feel bad but it's still hilarious oh my
god I keep dying on him it's really hard
in the right way to me I I got some time
to reflect on the game of and I gotta
say it's [ __ ] intense Rashmi you know
what I'd like this is run here first
before I say anything else
a real escaping now Oh God
I am too afraid to look good Oh Jeff
line please go
Oh God hi friend Hugh little asked what
he's so very evil some safe oh nice tits
I'm safe only here say did women - or
did he give them tits I think those are
fake tits oh my god I see it now
that's so [ __ ] [ __ ] up I mean those
are some nice [ __ ] jiggly ass titties
bed okay so I have to film it to
document it all right
okay let's go hi Fred mmm tastes like
strawberries all right I'm gonna use the
battery it's saved you thank God okay
nothing bad at all here it's pretty nice
actually if you think about it I'm
enjoying it thoroughly and I'm scared of
clicking don't kill me here it is right
yes you [ __ ] bucket [ __ ] I'm going
home mama don't dad please let me go
please
[Applause]
No
come on no come on what do I do
oh god it's ugly easy calling me fat I'm
too fat
oh no
what Oh God we had something special
you enjoy hanging around okay another
thing Dana out of ten how do we get back
here oh this way all right thank you
Wow I'll guess I'll see you later [ __ ]
oh thank god
thank God we finally made it don't tell
me I took a break right before the
ending of this game that'd be dumb
I have done this episode here please
leave a like everything go I'm watching
it helps me out a lot and it makes me
happy stay awesome bros see you tomorrow
[Music]